what the hell are you doing I'm not
standing next to him I didn't do it
I mean this is what I'm talking about
sweatpants wait did you tell him you
were gonna wear a sweatshirt tonight
I said please don't wear your sweatshirt
don't oh he skipped that word
listen this community
anyway first of all ma'am okay thank you
okay please and thank you I mean it's a
work of art it's I've never been sort of
so impressed by a few it's all hand
beated
so listen the way I was laughing in this
the way I was laughing in this one I'm
just gonna claim that there's gonna be a
third Jennifer I'm just gonna say it
that's your prediction I'll take it so
who would be on your list to get to
bring in Forth oh God you're asking me
right on on the uh God I don't know
where to even begin
um
uh uh oh gosh see what you did to me
here's my real question so in the movie
when the crime goes down it's at the big
party you're hanging by the buffet so I
wonder in real life where does Jennifer
Aniston hang out at a party usually
close to an exit
and this movie opens on a Friday night
so I wonder like what does a Friday
night look like for you what are you
doing if I just sit home and watch
Netflix and you know chill are you a
homebody because we're Birthday Twins
and I'm a homebody too yes I love being
at home and I love being at home with
with a group of friends I love you know
we love cooking dinners and we love
just like home we did come up with a
little bit of an idea the other day
about what a trio movie could be Three's
Company yes
fun man
[Applause]
yeah Barrymore explore the idea of maybe
doing a Three's Company remake what do
we
have
[Music]
the switch it depends on how everybody
responds to this film and if they
enjoyed themselves and had a good time
and Netflix will hopefully just say yep
and is it true that this guy was really
up to play Ross back in the day or was
he just
that's a very big possibility were you
really up to play Ross
he was dead
anyway so there's your answer there's
the answer all right gotcha thank you so
much all right good to see you
[Music]